Margot what's bothering you the movies
coming out in a few weeks and everyone's
just talking about how it's a squad full
of bad guys but there's more to it than
that you know for starters they're
actually really friendly and we have a
leader with tremendous accuracy yeah
jocas must be crazy teammates who many
would consider unstoppable I mean
absolute monsters interest does the
squad bend the rules sometimes sure
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people for bad guys but that's only
because they want to win and what's
wrong with winning huh I totally get it
haters give my squad a hard time too you
really get me rub your squad my squad we
can party Gronk style so crazy
so if you're confused by what's going on
here I've obviously just a very
tongue-in-cheek Margot Robbie Harley
Quinn Suicide Squad promo with Rob
drawing gelen Patriots the ESPY Awards
was tonight so that's basically what
this was posted during he was meant to
be an SPS trailer but that you know this
fun tongue-in-cheek ways to do Harley
Quinn things like this is a therapy
session before Harley Quinn became
Harley Quinn she was dr. Harleen Quinzel
at Arkham Asylum so this would have been
like a scene between her and the Joker
the movie is going to show us some of
that in flashbacks but it's you know
it's basically her just explaining the
movie for all the sports people that
really like the ESPYs but might not have
any idea what's going on with suicide
squad or never read the comics that's
actually been a trend lately where
they'll drop trailers during big
football games or basketball games
because the audience's use live sporting
events get higher ratings than almost
anything Walking Dead is one of the only
examples of a TV show that can actually
beat football ratings on Sunday nights
so naturally early ticket sales start on
Friday they want all these people to go
see it so they just make a very
accessible tongue-in-cheek version of
the trailer with Margot Robbie just
explaining things they're not bad guys
they're just trying to win the way they
play it this is actually on the set of
the movie so this might actually be the
inside of her office in Arkham Asylum
during the movie but you see some Easter
eggs let you see her jacket hanging in
the background you see her mallet you
see her baseball bat they actually had a
bunch of different versions of the
baseball bat that they had to create
just in case she broke them while they
were filming the funny thing about
margot robbie those is she's an aussie
that's why she's speaking with an
Australian accent but for like a brief
period during this trailer it almost
sounds like she's doing a Long Island
accent it just gets kind of hilarious
which I think that was the accident that
she used in wolf of Wall Street if i'm
not mistaken but because Comic Con is
next week and they are going to be
hyping the [ __ ] out of the movie there I
would expect a new big trailer to drop
in the movie comes out less than two
weeks after comic-con after their comic
con panel so it is going to be cranked
up next week so i'll be doing a whole
bunch of DC and Marvel videos there's a
bunch of other stuff too they'll be Game
of Thrones all kinds of crazy stuff so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and I'll say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner there's been
actually a lot of DC videos I was not
really expecting this to drop right now
strike Slifer you and a twenty-dollar
amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so i can get your
contact details but hopefully that
explains like what was going on with
this trailer i mean it's a little bit
funny but it's kind of hard if you don't
understand who this person is this is
rob Gronk that's what he means when he
says party grok style let me know what
you think about them doing
tongue-in-cheek trailers like this I
mean do you like you enjoy it when they
do funny stuff like this or do you just
want them to do traditional types of
trailers like Captain America Civil War
kind of did this thing where they just
had fun epromos with chris evans and
robert downey jr. like this one where
like he eats the last donut and Chris
Evans gets all pissed off morning Evans
danny is that the last donut with red
white and blue sprinkles what did I tell
you what happened if you ate the last
donut with red white blue sprinkles
little foggy on it but I think it was
something like raining down hell fire
that's right and Here I am without an
umbrella
I feel a storm growing hold on if we
don't play that back I'm canceling a
press tour I think sometimes these
actually work really well especially if
you've already dropped a couple really
big trailers but plenty more Suicide
Squad plenty more flash coming next week
there's a bunch of other DC stuff too
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click up here on the top
link for my other Suicide Squad trailer
videos that I just posted a lot of
Suicide Squad stuff lately and you can
click down here on the bottom for my
black flash video for the new pic that's
been floating around from the flash
season 3 thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five from buying
the screen you can't see my face right
now I'll see you guys tonight